uber lyft and sidecar they're all part
of the ride-sharing economy so loved by
urban dwelling Millennials and
distrusted by Democratic politicians
taxicab unions and salon.com headline
riders since a California judge has
ruled that uber has to shut down and pay
a fine unless it changes its ways we're
gonna move around Los Angeles today and
sort through some of the rumors you
might have heard that uber doesn't pay
its drivers well but it's dangerous
there's no background checks they don't
pick up in bad areas so I'm gonna call
up our first uber right now from reasons
Los Angeles headquarters and we're gonna
catch a ride our first driver Katherine
moved to LA from New York hoping to
start a new business she uses uber to
help pay the bills while she makes that
transition yeah exactly see like what
life is like because you really like
kill your car for $10 an hour
essentially yeah so that's about what it
shakes out to yeah I mean it seems like
more money because they don't take taxes
out all right so it's like Oh
in New York Catherine made a lot more
money because she worked as an attorney
so I couldn't resist the opportunity to
turn the conversation towards uber
there's this whole issue of like super
drivers avoid like the bad areas thanks
very much it's nice okay so those a fun
ride very candid and friendly driver and
actually left my phone in her car which
if you ever taken the cab and left
something in it you know what a
nightmare that would be but she did
bring it right back to me it was about
15 bucks for 11 mile ride which is
pretty reasonable and she dropped us off
here at the yellow cab company where
we're gonna interview Bill Rauch who's
one of the top anti over boys in Los
Angeles so you've raised a lot of safety
issues around
uber lyft sidecar the whole ride sharing
economy why is it safer to ride in a cab
than in an uber for instance all of our
drivers are background checked through
the FBI's system that involves the
taking of fingerprints and checking
against the FBI's national database
uber system relies on names and Social
Security numbers and has been shown to
be incomplete is there any actual
evidence that it's more dangerous to
ride in an uber than in a taxicab or is
it just fear-mongering
to bring up the background check issue
well it's not fear-mongering to bring up
actual circumstances the female
passenger in Houston who in April was
sexually assaulted only weeks after her
felon was released from prison that's
not fear mongering that's fact we don't
know that it's the fact that you're more
likely to be assaulted in an uber than
in a yellow cab
well we absolutely know that ubers
background check system doesn't work we
absolutely know
felons are behind the wheel because we
have these instances that are happening
in cities across the country we have
this recent administrative court ruling
against uber that said they're not
giving up enough data to the government
to be able to track you know where
they're picking up and not picking up is
that a good ruling we think it's totally
legitimate before the Public Utilities
Commission to want to understand what's
going on in the transportation side in
terms of whether there's areas that are
unmet in terms of demand uber agreed to
these rules and now they just don't want
to comply and that this is an example of
what you see around the world blatant
actually proud sort of defiance of any
sort of rules that might apply to them I
unknowingly ordered an uber plus instead
of an uber and so I got to ride in a
comfy Lincoln town car driven by a guy
named Joseph who fixes motorcycles when
he's not driving oh and reason sorry the
extra cash yeah make enough money and
are there certain like areas I guess
we're just a lot of people are right
that's where you want to be
you know maybe somebody's drunk it can't
try you know you get a lot of you get a
lot of those Galu - twelve - tribe
unlike our first driver Kathryn Joseph
was skeptical about the idea of being
treated like an employee by oh yeah
again like they don't hire you you come
apart what do you think of that a better
arrangement
you know they one thing I don't know
there's enough people out here to do
accommodate everybody yeah they got no
choice but competition don't
thanks so much very nice meeting you sir
we're here on South Figueroa in one of
the neighborhoods ranked by the LA Times
is one of the most violent in the city
in front of Tam's number six which I
actually made another recent TV video
about so you can check that out we're
gonna get some lunch real quick they
have delicious burgers here then we're
gonna catch our last uber of the day it
was about an eight-minute wait for our
last uber which shouldn't be all that
surprising after a recent study of the
Los Angeles market found you were
actually picked up twice as fast and
suppose at rough neighborhoods as did
yellow taxi cabs our last driver was an
African immigrant named Marvin he says
he sends back a good portion of his uber
money to family in Sierra Leone the
Africans when you in America
things you're making money just like
that yeah so you really have to really
work hard to be able to take care of
your families back home so this job is
really helping me along and you come
from another country and sometimes it's
hard to get a job I had to wait for a
year because I mean I'm not from here
but my license
as long as you have good driving record
and you have a car you hit them in just
media requirements you know
what do you think about the cab groups
and the politicians who want to restrict
like this kind of thing on a strictly
uber and lyft I do talk to my my
passengers and I do believe that the
service we render it's more of what is I
mean if you are appreciated a lot that
they can that's the reason why we get in
more customers the airport they're gonna
start letting ubers pickup
I don't feel about this yeah yeah just
hang around they're very close to the
Airbus and that's what I do
you guys just quit your job is a baby
his wife just gave as it doesn't this
job
thank you pleasure meeting you too
our last stop is Los Angeles's Airport
lax where we'll catch a good
old-fashioned yellow cab since I already
blew my uber plus budget on the ride to
Sam's and the city prohibits uberx from
doing airport pickups although I hear
that if you set your location point just
outside the airport and call your driver
they'll come pick you up anyway just
name our driver wasn't in a particularly
talkative mood goober do you hurt us
uber yeah
what do you
what do you think a lot Hoover say look
man I know you're trying to interview me
but I really don't like it please you'd
rather not talk okay I'm like okay so it
was a quiet ride home but I can't really
blame the guy he's just trying to do his
job what good can come of talking to a
joker like me I took the time to reflect
on my earlier rides are they being
exploited by uber what I can tell you is
that some uber drivers I talked to
wanted to make more money and some
thought the money was pretty good and
we're even considering going full-time
the flexibility of the gig was really
important to all of them some people
might say that it's no big deal that
getting an uber in South LA was easy
sometime a pretty white looking dude but
the LA based study on the issue drew
from an ethnically diverse group of 18
riders and as far as background checks
go it's true that they don't run the
same FBI fingerprint check that yellow
cabs have to run which is why William
brows thinks more ex-cons are prone to
slip through the cracks but they do have
a rating system in real-time GPS
tracking that you think would act as at
least somewhat of a deterrent to doing
terrible things to their passengers all
the time and even raus wouldn't go so
far as to say that you're more likely to
be assaulted in an uber than in a cab
but don't trust me try it yourself in my
experience uber drivers love talking
about what it's like being over drivers